winter tragödie in pakistan mindestens
22 menschen darunter zehn kinder starben
in einem beliebten ferienort in den
bergen sie saßen während eines schweren
schneesturms über nacht in ihren autos
fest wie die polizei mitteilte erfroren
mindestens sechs menschen in ihren wagen
während sie im stau standen es wird
vermutet dass weitere insassen an den
abgasen erstickt
zehntausende besucher wollten den
ungewöhnlich starken schneefall sehen
und strömten in die pakistanische stadt
nur rund 70 kilometer nordöstlich von
islamabad
die stadt mit ihren rund 30.000
einwohnern gilt als malerische
urlaubsort letztendlich steckten
unzählige autos stoßstange an stoßstange
auf der straße fest das militär wurde
mobilisiert um die straßen zu räumen und
tausende von menschen zu retten die
feststeckten die regionalregierung der
provinz punjab erklärte moore zum
katastrophengebiet und forderte die
menschen auf sich von der 2300 meter
hoch gelegenen stadt fernzuhalten